that's good mm-hmm if I was eating with
my eyes I wouldn't eat this one who
cooked this thanks Jeff wasn't rested
properly hi my name is Diana I am a
professional sous chef Anna hi my name
is Yoli and I am a chef de cuisine and
today we are trying to guess cheap
versus expensive steak I love steak I
love steak a lot I am praying that I
could get this right or else I'm gonna
have to change careers because I can't I
can't go back to work knowing that I
can't tell the difference between a
cheap steak and a expensive one
well my mouth is watering so I'm very
excited I mean I'm seeing the sauce I'm
excited can we just do this it's a meat
all right yeah are you ready I've get
fancy a pharisee napkins Hey set the
mood Cheers
this one first right let's go so it
looks pretty good I would say it is a
New York strip see those grill marks I
do see the grill marks on I do
appreciate ready yes it does feel pretty
tender on the fork all right all right
let's go
mmm definitely not chewing mm-hmm not as
tender as I thought it would be mm-hmm
was arrested properly it was definitely
a little bit chewy not as tender I
thought it would be more tender since it
was cooked medium ish my guess right now
is that this is somewhere in the middle
yeah next okay this one looks it's just
a longshot we'll find out if it's good
fat or not good not right now the tender
good flavor this is good
mm-hmm when you have steak there's
marbling involved where there's like the
meat and the fat mixed in between and
that causes the steak to be a little bit
more tender when you cook it but
sometimes cheaper pieces of meat have
like a big old piece of fat on the side
or in between and it causes it to be a
little bit rough um I would say this is
a little bit higher in comparison it's
better because it's more flavorful
better season and the second you bite
into it you get a lot of flavor in your
mouth yeah beef tastes like beef mm-hmm
good job who cooked this thanks Jeff
we don't want looks to be deceiving
yeah if I was eating with my eyes I
wouldn't eat this one
Oh see this is a bad fat I'm talking
about I know this is gonna be like rough
right here when I when I bite into it
but don't judge by cover of the stick we
judged correctly this is the cheap steak
mm-hmm it was very tough the fat that I
had in it dry dry it was also a little
overcooked but yeah I didn't the flavor
wasn't there
yeah I felt bad about eating this ciao
if you don't have to go down for this no
he could have just lived you could have
lived yeah definitely
oh wow look at that one
disco alright this is nice it looks like
the temperature is perfect no you saw
how my fork does JIT he's gone in there
good has good flavor yeah flavorful
tender seasoned not as good as that one
yeah the flavor on this one was a lot
better yeah it didn't really have that
as much fat in it as this one but it was
way better than these two I would say it
is the second yeah it's like high but
not number one
[Music]
okay so I think we both agree yeah this
is one being the one yeah the worst and
then we're gonna go to two three and
this is the most expensive one yes
please tell me I'm right yeah I'm dying
so this we guess it's number two
yes the second cheapest are we right yes
all right so this one that one is the
most most expensive see I'm really
nervous about this okay so this one is
the cheapest date yes
and obviously this one is the second
most expensive is the second down I
would say the number one tell for me is
the mouthfeel for sure you show the ones
that were easier to chew and like like
it was an explosion of flavor fat is
flavor and I feel like this one had a
good amount of balance of like me and
fat a lot of marbling and this one
didn't but if you chop this up and
season it really well you can make some
talk yeah I think we did great
I was very nervous about this we picked
the right career
[Music]